and jamison taiom will get the start for
the yankees this will be a six start his
last timeout his best start so far one
and two 5.24 29 strikeouts in 22 and a
third inning
rounded to first they try out and duhor
right away
one down always works like that paul
it'll find you the 2-2
swung on and popped him up off a
fastball
and there is
the second baseman wade
grounded
right to torres and he guns down
soto for the final out here's patrick
for his
sick start
31 years old 6-3 2-10 last start may 1st
against the marlins 7-2 winner gave up
just two runs on four hits over seven dj
lemayo will lead off
18-51 with four home runs against corbin
here's the 1-1
swung on a high fly to right
and that ball is gonna be
gone in the first row hernandez went
back
timed his leap and it just got over as
his fifth home run against corbin
dj
david john makes long gone 300th career
hit with the yankees and the second
fastest to do it he did in his 225th
game yankees won that's nothing josh
bell leading off against jameson taiyo
bell out to deep center
and see
you later josh bell straight away so who
needs the short fortune right that's his
third of the year rbi number 10
and that's a big fly in a big part of
that ballpark john gomes is next
and the fastball gomes rips it to left
c
u
later
a low laser out of the ballpark and jan
gomez with his fourth the nats are on
top three to one gomes is swinging a hot
bat he has started six games in a row to
coincide with that six game hitting
streak so that extended playing time has
him in a good rhythm at the plate
there's gary sanchez two hits in his
last 30 at bats
that one's driven deep to left field
going back schwarber looking up see ya
home run for sanchez and it's 3-2 knacks
sanchez
really needed that the yankees can't
wait for him to start hitting like the
old gary sanchez that's a slider that
he's so good with but he kept it right
there gary sanchez knew it right off the
bat
up the middle
backhanded beautifully by tyler wade and
he turns it into an out
wade made a heck of a play that ball was
hit hard
and at him and he had to
put up the glove and get it back-handed
so there's one away so one away and
here's josh harrison
that one is drilled deep to left center
field on the run is frazier
he does and he makes the play
oh what a play by clint frazier
he did it in cleveland he did it here
landing on his chest like he's taking a
belly flop
into the pool
the pitch to gomes hit on the ground a
third dj scoops it up throws across one
away
slow roller
right to tyonne
two way tyon's dealing now
high fly ball
center field hicks is there it's 11 in a
row for jamison tyone
now the pitch swung on line to center
again robles coming in a few steps there
and he makes the catch
almost an instant replay of his first
at-bat
this one slapped to the other side josh
harrison to his left
challenge heater
bell has it
two pitchers on a roll that's 11 of 12
for corbin
and he goes down on strikes turner does
they get the
angle one two hit on the ground to short
glebra backhand sets throws two way
the three-two
strike three soto down looking for the
second time
how about this run for chao he's retired
the last 14 nationals dj tonight as
homered
that's how he began the game for the
yanks
that one's driven deep to right field
giving chase hernandez thai ball game
see ya second home run of the night for
le mayhew say at some point if you're
corbin you might just want to throw four
balls and sliders supposed to be in but
he left it up out over the plate and if
you're not looking to pull pinkie
stadium's a wonderful place to hit
and with one out and pitch the bell is
swung on a high fly
to shallow right center there's judge
coming in walking in makes the catch one
pitch
one out tyonne gets a big hand as
peralta will come in
2-0 here hitters count
and yadiel all over that one into right
center
judge over to cut it off and he boots it
hernandez sees that goes into second and
then adds get a break on a single and an
error
that's a good heart punt that makes the
third baseman come forward and
the throw pulling and duhar off the bag
so the yankees another miss q and then
that's half first and third nobody out
and turn to the banner oh for three he's
due
turner slaps one right through the
infield and the gnats are back on top
josh harrison is all for two against
this right-hander with a strikeout the
kick and the pitch to harrison swung on
and belted to left field this is deep
this is way back this is going going and
go on goodbye
bang zoom goes harrison no doubt about
it off the crack of the bat
a laser beam to left for harrison
and a big eighth inning for the
nationals it's now washington seven in
new york three
base it right field soto coming around
he's being waved home
throw is late play at second
out oh the ball dropped schwarber
appeared to be out but then the ball was
dropped and the nats are just running
all over yankee stadium right now
gomes and that one by the glove of
taurus
castro scores
and he'll get juan soto now
that breaking ball he waited for it hit
it a long way to left center
cu later oppo for juan soto
two for five his third of the year he's
back in the lineup and the nats are into
double digits here's miguel and duhar
who's over three in his 2021 debut
fastball turner short way and the nets
take care of business late
and it's a real feel-good win for the
nats on the road against the mighty
yankees tonight